coming up on 5 26 on your monday morning
got an update on those mystery polls
that have been popping up in the middle
of this trip near the welcome to las
vegas sign and some full disclosure i
have not done anywhere near the research
that john langler's done for his report
on ancestry
but i don't think i'm going out on a
limb to say that these polls are not
[Music]
the great great great grand nieces and
nephews of the interplanetary invaders
from the fictional war of the worlds
martian cylinders are falling all over
the country first one is crossing the
river
when eight news now viewer kurt asked
about the polls we learned from clark
county they're simply called smart poles
combination light poles with space to
install cell phone sites well county
public information officer dan hulen
says the polls are owned and were
installed with the county pointing out
that they've also been put in on the
strip around resorts world noting that
most of them do have the sell side
equipment already on board
okay so we don't for when those cell
sites are going to be activated we're
just glad that the smart poles are not
from mars buckle up drive carefully
please put down that phone something's
driving you crazy email me traffic
dot com